هو القاضي الذي كفر يده اكثر من 40 مره
عاد بعد غياب تخطى العام اشهر انتفاضته
القضائيه بوجه محاولات جماعيه لعرقلتي سير
العداله
وبعد ان اجاز المحقق العدلي طارق البيطار
لنفسه استئناف التحقيقات انفجار المرفق
قبل بالصدفه
عويدات قرار استدعائه رسميا ضمن لائحه من
ثمانيه اشخاص على راسها ايضا المدير العام
للامن العام اللواء عباس ابراهيم الذي منع
البيطار من استدعائه سابقا
قرار اثلج قلوب اهالي الضحايا بعد ان بحث
حناجرهم مطالبين باستئناف التحقيقات
راي قانوني مخالف ممكن مراجعه المحاكم
المختصه مثل ما حتى هو باراره اشار لهذا
الموضوع انه اليوم المجلس العدلي عنده
الصلاحيه في ابطال او باعتبار ايه تحقيقات
غير
منا بموقع اما المساله الثانيه لليوم عم
تتحرك اكثر هي موقف ان هي بالعامه من
مساله خلقت السبيل بحق الموقوفين بالملف
اليوم في خمس اخلاء
اليوم مصير تنفيذه او عدم تنفيذه مجهول
على اثرها ازدحمت ارجوك تقصر العدل بحسب
المعلومات بمبتدينا من المده عليهم
الوزراء المحسوبين على حزب الله هو حركتي
امل
ووسطنا خوف النيه وشارع شبيه بشارع السابع
من ايار ومخاطر قد يتعرض لها البيطار
تحدثت اوساطه قاضي التحقيق عن قيامه بما
يمليه عليه ضميره وان ما يخشى عليه فقط هو
مسار التحقيقات
تعمل
المنطقه
المستمر بالقضاء يتركب الشارع اللبناني
ردود فعل من استدعاهم القضاء في قضيه
احداثها بعد تجميدها لاكثر من عام وصى
مطالبات دوليه بتحقيقا عادل وشفاف غن
ويتيم العربيه بيروت